un jeune yvelinois originaire de
Sartrouville va bientôt monter les
marches du festival de Cannes Youssef 18
ans a participé au projet moteur il
s'agit d'un concours de films ouverts
aux jeunes de 14 à 22 ans le défi faire
le portrait d'une personne qui les
inspire en une minute trente l'objectif
est également de donner confiance aux
jeunes
issus de tout milieu dans une démarche
inclusive pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de vous lancer dans ce projet
moteur
ça me plaît et moi bah ça fait longtemps
que j'ai voulu être dans le cinéma au
début ça a pas marché comme je vous l'ai
dit ensuite on m'a proposé un concours
et j'ai saisi l'occasion et j'ai voulu
participer à payer alors comment ça
c'est fait comment est-ce qu'on vous a
proposé le concours comment est-ce que
vous êtes tombé dessus
du coup qui savait que je voulais être
dans le cinéma et bah il a fait
plusieurs courts-métrages
qui ont fonctionné du coup bah il m'a
proposé de faire un court-métrage je
l'ai je l'ai fait et
vous aviez
déjà
j'en ai pas fait pour un concours j'en
ai fait la vie quotidienne mais pour un
concours c'est la première fois que je
fais un court métrage
que vous aimez déjà bien ça
passion pour le cinéma en regardant des
films ça me plaît les films j'aime trop
les films et bah tout ce qui est comique
action et
franchement moi je suis dans ça dans ce
sport aussi c'est quoi votre film
préféré film préféré c'est surtout les
films comiques moi je suis plus dans les
films comiques et dans les films
d'action et du coup plus tard vous avez
envie de faire un métier dans dans
l'univers du cinéma ce serait quoi
plutôt du coup réalisateur scénariste
vous avez déjà une idée de réalisateur
mais aussi acteur ça j'aimerais bien
faire acteur en premier et si bah j'ai
pas l'occasion j'essayerai réalisateur
mes données
à un repas participé au projet moteur
vous lui donne quoi comme conseils
et ça peut fonctionner la preuve et donc
pour ce concours vous avez choisi de
parler de Martin Luther King pourquoi
cette personnalité pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle vous inspire le sujet bah c'est
le sujet c'est quelque chose qui vous
inspire et moi j'habite dans un endroit
où la rue Saint-Martin Luther King du
coup bah je vais choisir Martin Luther
King parce que il m'inspire parce qu'il
a fait des grandes choses un combat de
jeu pour les personnes de couleur et ça
ça m'a beaucoup inspiré et j'ai voulu
faire sur Martin Luther King mais alors
avant d'en parler davantage je vous
propose justement de regarder ce mini
film réalisé par Youssef sur Martin
Luther King
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ste ouverte avec plein de métiers on est
en terminale moi j'ai envie de devenir
mère je vais voir comment on fait cette
formation tout simple moi j'en invite et
moi
avocats
toi journaliste et toi voca Simon de la
fiche
c'est un président
on va se poser on va faire un match
écoutez le pas venons voilà journée
portes ouvertes pas qu'on a des origines
d'immigré et combien doit de citer
défavorisées qu'on va pas réussir
regarde Martin Luther King mes frérot tu
t'appelles Benny Yanis il m'a demandé là
tout à l'heure et tu crois que vous
allez réussir
Martin Luther King a été détruit il est
des gens il a formé il était avocat il
aidait les gens et il était surtout mère
donc ça a l'air politique et c'est du
parking de la rue ils sont en faire 3
chacun d'entre nous prend en faire un
[Musique]
du coup c'est avec vos amis que vous
avez tourné ce film avec mes amis et du
coup ça se passe à Sartrouville dans le
quartier où vous avez grandi dans le
quartier qui est la cité des Indes à
retrouver et ben j'ai fait ça avec mes
amis bah dans la rue Martin luthering
c'est pour ça que voilà
vous avez créé le scénario
comme je vous ai dit j'ai lâché un petit
peu la faire parce que ça marchait pas
et du coup bah là je me suis dit
pourquoi pas faire un scénario ou je
lâche l'affaire et je crois pas aux
autres et bah pour montrer comme quoi
j'ai réussi et au final faut pas lâcher
l'affaire c'est c'est ce message là que
vous avez voulu faire passer dans cette
vidéo
et donc selon vous qu'est-ce qui a fait
la différence au niveau du jury du jury
d'ailleurs présidé par Oxmo Puccino et
d'autres acteurs culturels
institutionnels engagés pour les jeunes
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
auprès du jury selon vous selon moi je
pense que j'ai été plus à l'aise et que
je savais un peu ce que je faisais et
que je voulais réussir et que je voulais
vraiment y participer à ce concours et
alors ce 25 mai la semaine prochaine
vous avez rendez-vous avec les célèbres
marche du Festival de Cannes vous savez
déjà comment ça va se passer quel est le
programme sur place vous allez être
accompagné on va être accompagné je sais
qu'on va aller pour monter les marches
et qu'on va rencontrer des personnes un
peu plus professionnelles qui
connaissent un peu plus et pourquoi pas
y apprendre davantage et
il y aura nos têtes et nos visages
exposés à la gare de Cannes
vous espérez aussi rencontrer des stars
du cinéma
particulier
je sais que des films au marché
surtout ceux qui sont dans l'action et
qui sont marrants qui vous inspirent
aussi aujourd'hui pourquoi
famille vos amis quand vous avez appris
que vous avez été sélectionné bah ils
étaient heureux c'était content ils ont
vu que bah j'avais lâché l'affaire et
que j'ai repris et ben j'étais heureux
pour moi aussi du coup j'étais heureux
il me dit pas faut pas lâcher pour la
prochaine et pour la suite
et vous avez d'autres peut-être dans le
cinéma à venir
peut-être de plus en plus grand au
niveau du cinéma et pourquoi pas faire
comme ce que j'aime bien comme
l'aventure continue puisque vous allez
pouvoir suivre des ateliers sur sur du
slam du théâtre et de l'éloquence vous
l'attendez avec impatience
je veux tout ce qui est possible de
faire pour aller plus loin je veux le
faire c'est je veux aller sur ce sur ce
chemin vous avez une préférence parmi le
théâtre le cinéma le slam le cinéma
et bien merci beaucoup Youssef d'avoir
répondu à nos questions on vous souhaite
un décollage vous avez une dernière
question non j'ai cru on vous souhaite
un bon festival de Cannes et donc si
vous aussi vous êtes intéressé par le
projet moteur vous retrouverez toutes
les informations sur le site Internet
qui s'affiche juste en dessous en bas de
votre écran pour pouvoir participer
l'année prochaine